c'est parti mon jean pierre levac alors
attention pas de bananes ont il faut des
réponses rapides et sens et on en
réponse du tac au tac et ne pas répéter
plusieurs fois le même au top c'est
parti
benjamin as tu va bien tout va très bien
c'est que deux plus jeunes enfants de la
famille benjamin je ne sais pas si ça
lui dire ses deux plus petits le
pigeonneau je ne crois pas non il faut
répondre du tac au tac le plus rapide
possible
on y va et oui tu étais pas
[Musique]
bonjour bonjour il faut un petit peu
totalement calme ce qui du ski vous
pratiquez de ski de la luge et des quiz
bas bonjour bonjour comprend si tous les
matins bah c'est bon heureuse et
mécanique engins mécaniques mécanique
jamais que les permis de conduire
je les ai vus en voiture là je suis venu
en nombre et variés gelée était un bon
garçon célibataire célibataire et des
enfants dans des deux et quel sport
pratiquer le golf ou monter à cheval
non
[Applaudissements]
j'ai dit bonjour c'est là qu'est dit
toujours toujours à deux elles que
hollande est bien d'accord que mort pour
tuvalu à kevin origines nous va bien
parisienne lequel paris band pas paris
même non je dis pas
alors avec gmail était la preuve vous
mettez moi mais on compte sur toi allez
pierre tu vas gagner un truc tu vas
gagner ce week end
enfin attention top-départ bonsoir
bonsoir on sait déjà rencontré tous les
deux que jamais si jamais guillemets ça
arrête d'être vilain rajouter les noms
j'en vois notre centre jean luc lemoine
derniers espoirs ses 200 ans
deux cents ans de ninon jeune âge avait
dit oui il n'a jamais dit non ils
allaient me dit je ne sais pas il n'a
jamais dit qui y est vous on va jouer
dans un instant
oh non je vous le dis après si jean luc
lemoine père le ni oui ni non
j'annule l'émission sur la tête de ma
mère
[Applaudissements]
je ne réponds pas aux parts avec tout le
public
je vous le dis et je voudrais je ne
parle pas du tout si jean luc lemoine
père le ni oui ni non
on se barre est tout public pourra tout
se mange et on commence à moi d'en
savoir avait très bien il est arrivé le
petit peu en retard je suis arrivé en
retard tout état je suis très content ce
numéro la réserve pourtant je pense que
j'ai un rôle très important lors des
poteaux 12 avoir ouvert le feu mais
c'est parler
la ville est très belle mais oui
d'ailleurs top
bonsoir ça va mieux ça va bien ça va ça
va très bien et de ce fait divers cette
année je ne vais jamais jamais de sport
d'hiver de n'était pas ça je n'aime pas
le second référé les studio théâtre le
théâtre se garde bien j'adore je joue un
jeu télévisé
calme-toi jean-pierre un jeu télévisé
l'avait déjà fait j'ai déjà participé
deux trois fois je vous ai fait j'ai
fait le juste de frais blick juste prix
mais juste prix oui
[Musique]
si nadal ou alors si vous nous rejoignez
à cause de jean luc lemoine en équipe
j'ai dû faire un restaurant dont le
plateau on pas pogner jean luc barbo
[Applaudissements]